coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 16 I should
start by saying I'm more of an anti
theist than an atheist in other words my
view is not just that there is no reason
to believe that there is a deity and
that all the arguments that there is one
have all long since been exploded by
philosophers astronomers scientists
physicists biologists and so forth
mainly by philosophers there in my
opinion um but that it's a good thing
that that's not the case
how do we describe Christopher Hitchens
as a writer journalist teacher political
commentator contrarian atheists
extremely adept debater as a champion of
truth democracy whiskey and a piece of
advice his mother gave him when he was
just a young boy that the only
unforgivable sin is to be boy yvonne's
advice was never forgotten issues became
one of the most successful and
penetrating thinkers of his time
publishing several books tearing down
sacred cows from mother Teresa
fanatical albanian dwarf lying thieving
Ullman
Bill Clinton no I think he is even by
even by the most relaxed standard an
unusually Hollow and empty and cold
individual and completely ruthless Henry
Kissinger war criminal is Henry
Kissinger's
job description and has been since he
first caught Richard Nixon's eye and the
one and only got the Christian answers
of course you have free will
the boss insists upon it he lionize
Jefferson Orwell Thomas Paine he wrote
columns for Vanity Fair Slate Magazine
the Atlanta he was a prolific in viber
and inhaler two things which no doubt
shortened his life in the end but hitch
was too smart not to know that you get
out of alcohol what you put into it as
he was a scotch man like me and a Johnny
Walker man like me I can only say simply
everything in moderation take two and as
he was a scotch man like me and a Johnny
Walker man like me I can only say three
take four everything in moderation takes
out breakfast of champions read his work
for yourself agree with him
my point is not to vindicate his Timmy
crystal regions represent something the
world is always in short supply of men
and women of letters intellectual and
unapologetic for beings sometime in the
last couple of centuries intellectuals
lost their credit the Western view and
just when they were doing so good in the
Enlightenment in our time the word
intellectual has come to be synonymous
with pretend but anti-intellectualism
is an old and repetitive story it made
itself a home in Mussolini's Italy
Stalin's Russia Hitler's Germany where
you can trace it back in time through
religion all the way to the death of
Socrates or you can move forward in time
to the populism of politicians like
George W Bush I like to mountain bike I
like on my ipod that old strategy where
intellectuals are pitted against the
uncorrupt salt in the earth good to have
a beer with folk like this anti
intellectualism is troubling in all its
manifestations but maybe nowhere more so
than in youth culture they want to be
cool they are impressionable and they
have the cash they are corporate
America's one hundred fifty billion
dollar dream the idea here is that the
advertising industry has transformed the
language thought and actions of
teenagers into commodities in order to
sell them popular reading a generation
who is completely uninterested in
maturing to adult take this how you want
there is certainly a good point here but
what I saw in myself and others as a
young teenager was that being an idiot
is easy it's amazing when you're an
idiot everything that comes out of your
mouth is idiotic with no work at all but
when you want to be intelligent
everything you say requires a little
work a little bit of thought and effort
to compose yourself so it's not to be an
a nor contradictory or we're done this
doesn't mean that intellectuals can't be
silly it doesn't mean that we can't turn
our brains off every once in a while we
all need them being an intellectual no
matter how you slice it is hard it takes
introspection and time and a willingness
to be critical of yourself and it never
stops being hard it gets hard the reward
is that hard work becomes the reward
learning becomes a commodity as bright
and infinitely renewable as the Sun
everyone can and should be an
intellectual whether you're a doctor or
a plumber or president or adjourn all
this takes is putting yourself on the
record it takes writing something and
submitting it to the public for if
you're a painter or lawyer filmmaker
dancer that's great but still right a
musician engineer or diplomat accountant
fantastic what still words are the units
of thought and if you listen to anything
I say let it be this we learn by saying
not think
ideas are like clouds you can't hold
onto when we compose a sentence we make
the ideas solve then we can put it in
our pockets and take it with us what do
you think it takes to lead a good life
um for me
irony literature as the source of
reflection on moral and ethical and
human topics laughing at the misfortunes
of others that gets me through a lot of
the day love and some of the things that
go with the possibility of passing on
your genes to children the only kind of
immortality or now again and did I
mention this already laughing at the
misfortune rose and and it being proved
right being vindicated in arguments that
were other people wish they hadn't had
with you they have to say okay I was
wrong in you right